hi there I'm gonna do the third one of
these few things that I wanted to say
and I'm going to talk about rosetta
stone and I'm gonna talk about the
structure lists and the I would call it
the people who want to hear the tune
first and I'll explain why I put it in
those terms I think in terms of language
learning there are two positions that I
see one is the position that we need to
learn the structure first otherwise we
will be reinforcing a poor grasp of the
structure and in that camp we have the
people who want to teach grammar who
want to force you to get the grammar
writings who want to do grammar tests
who want you to understand explanations
or even the learners who feel that they
have to have a grasp of the grammar
before they can learn a language and
also in that category our rosetta stone
and I'll explain why even though rosetta
stone claims to be a departure from
traditional language learning in fact
they're very much structuralist sand in
fact that was confirmed to me this
morning in the discussion that I had
with their director of learning so
that's the structures first you learn
the structure the other position which
is the position of a stephen krashen
which is my position which is that you
need words you need a familiarity with
the language but this is best acquired
through a lot of listening especially
listening and reading which crashing
pushes and in doing this you start to
get a feel for the language and at
various times in that process of
acquiring the language and acquiring
words you can occasionally review the
structure and that the structure will
gradually become clearer to you mostly
because you've been exposed to it too a
great deal but to some extent because of
these
no explanations or Corrections or other
kind of teacher input so the first group
the structuralist s-- are very much
teacher centered and this other approach
which is my approach
crashing approach is more learner
discovering the language most people are
much more familiar with the first
approach and that's why many people come
to link and they don't understand what
we're doing however I am quite convinced
of the most successful language learners
famous polyglots or countries like
sweden where people watch TV in English
the the successful language learners
have overwhelmingly been people who take
the approach of getting the language in
getting familiar with it acquiring words
through experience letting the brain get
used to it
with a minimal a minimal amount of
specific instruction now this morning as
I mentioned in my previous video I sat
in on an e conference and I had the
opportunity to listen to Dwayne cider si
Dr who's the head of learning at rosetta
stone and his presentation was not so
much about rosetta stone but rather
about it was a very general discussion
about what he considered to be the new
role of the teacher which is that of a
sheepdog as he put it as a coordinator
and that the teacher has to learn from
the students and of course this is what
everyone is saying today it's so
commonplace it's become a trite cliché
but very few people actually walk the
talk and so I commented that I have been
through rosetta stone and rosetta stone
in fact imposes very specific contexts
here is a boy drinking a juice here is a
girl drinking tea what are they doing
you got you know you say it or you have
a choice of multiple choice to get it
right or you you speak very early on in
your study of the language you try to
say it and even in the more advanced
version they have
a very specific scenario and you're
supposed to respond to the scenario and
you're supposed to speak and I'd
commented to mr. Schneider I said you
know what I found very limiting is that
that Redis rosetta stone imposes through
very nice videos imposes a context I may
not be interested there was a picture of
some people doing some painting the
ladders quality falling over I'm not
interested in people painting in a
ladder falling over I am interested in
hearing about things that interest me
and I want to choose what I want to
listen to and I want to go on and on and
on acquiring more of the language as I
learn about things that are of interest
to me and I don't want to have to speak
in lesson one or lesson 2 or less than
three I want to speak when I'm ready I
want to choice I want to discover the
language on my own so you know there are
those and I had a discussion coming back
from the the language teachers
conference with the teacher someone who
had studied English he was a Chinese
origin and she said that oh she had to
have grammar if he didn't have the
grammar you just continue making the
mistakes I believe that that's not true
because you don't need to use the
language initially all you need to do is
get it in you by listening and reading
you can't make a mistake if you're only
listening and reading you're not
required to produce the language so
those are two positions the
structuralists and the the natural ists
I call it and the natural to my mind are
more like my wife no need to play the
piano only now after three four or five
years of enjoying playing music reading
music enjoying gradually getting better
now she's starting to be interested in
the chords and and the relationship
between the notes and call it theory but
if you had tried to present that to her
at the beginning she would have probably
stopped playing piano and and part of
the whole thing about instruction is
that it's a nice feeling that you know
something of
student doesn't know so you can explain
to them but it's a bit like getting as
you know instructions on where to go if
you you say well I'm looking for
such-and-such a theatre and a person
says well you go down to the church you
turn left you'll see a schoolyard you go
three streets passes schoolyard and
you'll see that there's a park and then
there's two big trees and you go down
there and the person is giving you these
instructions very pleased because they
know exactly where the schoolyard is
where the church is where the two trees
are whatever and they're able to give
you this knowledge but you've never been
down that road you haven't a clue what
they're talking about as soon as they
finish explaining where the schoolyard
in the tree in the church and the trees
are you've forgotten it meant nothing to
you but if you have walked down or
driven down that road three or four
times then those explanations start to
make sense and that's exactly what I
feel with language learning in theory it
would be nice if you could get all the
structure explained to you and then you
can go ahead and and you would be able
to understand so much better the fact is
though in my own experience I may be
exceptional but I find that I cannot
understand the explanations until I have
had enough exposure and I am quite
comfortable reading and listening and
not understanding everything I am
confident in the knowledge that I am
gradually getting used to the language
and that at some point these
explanations that I read every couple of
months and still don't understand at
some point they're gonna click in and
what's more not only will I understand
them but at some point I'll naturally
start to use them correctly because it
will seem natural to me to say it this
way rather than that way so that's a
quick take on the structuralist which is
the grammar teachers and rosetta stone
and the naturist and i feel the
advantage with the natural ists is the
way we learn at linked I like to learn
is that the course never ends you just
continue to grow in the language
following your interests and doing
things that are interesting putting in
the time
and in fact this gets me to one of the
statements I heard at the conference in
San Diego which I totally agree with and
that is language learning boils down to
motivation time on task and
attentiveness and so if you're motivated
to learn if you have interesting things
to listen to you're gonna put in the
time you're gonna be motivated and a
little bit of flashcard review a little
bit of grammar instruction a little bit
of this and that every now and then
correction it all helps to make you
attentive a lot of the functions we have
and Link the highlighting of different
words it helps to make you attend it so
slowly you start to notice things better
and better but that's still sort of a
more natural way to learn one that I
find more effective and ultimately
faster so that's the last of my three
videos this evening and now I'm going to
go and read a book thank you for
listening